a big meeting in the state capitol today
one assemblyman calling it a culmination
of a near two-year effort to put
pandemic relief funds to good use
three-quarters of a billion dollars were
discussed and allocated by the interim
finance committee spearheaded by a 100
million dollar investment in water
infrastructure that will be spread
across water conservation efforts as
well as repairing aged and leaking
systems also approved 250 million
towards affordable housing plus over 100
million dollars for physical and mental
health systems now Republic candidate
for governor Joe Lombardo took exception
however to the 140 million dollars
slotted for quote government
modernization now his team issuing this
statement inflation is at a 40-year
record high meanwhile Steve sisilak has
spent our tax dollars expanding
government bureaucracy instead of
delivering solutions for nevadans
sicilak can't keep the DMV open can't
get anyone to answer the phone at the
unemployment office and he refuses to
pay our state police a living wage
that's not leadership end quote